oh
these young fighters in algeria are
blazing their own trail mixed martial
arts has been growing in popularity in
the country in recent years but while a
number of algerian men compete
internationally the women's mma scene is
still at an early stage
despite that there's no shortage of
ambition at this gym in the western city
of clemson where more than 70 girls
train
we entered this sport to avoid street
problems and aggression against women
societies seem to believe women are weak
after i started this sport i loved it
and i wanted to develop myself and
participate in championships too
women in algeria are no strangers to
combat sports the north african nation
recently hosted the mediterranean games
and fielded females in events such as
karate and judo while boxer amani khalif
was their flag bearer at the opening
ceremony
the 23 year old went on to win a gold
medal and those involved in developing
mma in algeria hope the fighters they're
bringing through can also enjoy success
in the future
society and families were afraid of mma
but now it's good girls can practice the
sport like any other and there's
acceptance by society and families now
women practice this sport without
difficulty
if these fighters are in need of
inspiration they don't need to look too
far as the middle east and north africa
already boast some impressive female mma
competitors one of the best female
fighters
i've seen in the in the last uh couple
of years would be hasn't
recently signed with a international mma
promotion pfl on the amateur level
we saw sandra sukhar who won the gamma
world championship sandra sukhar is
lebanese
fighters at this gym know they've got a
long way to go if they're to succeed in
the world of mma for now none of them
show signs of tapping out anytime soon
sohail malik al jazeera